oggi un mega con shopping
ho comprato un sacco di sly domanda
perché aiuto il verbo è stato dal mio
parte oggi per vedere tutte le cose che
ho comprato come lo slime come potete
vedere comprato un sacco di cose
questa cosa mi incuriosisce un sacco è
una lunga una specie di kit nuovo della
cleopatra e c'è scritto buco di unicorno
sono futuri codesto di vedere cosa c'è
dentro è come è fatto questo che
dovremmo vedere bene che queste cose che
abbiamo comprato se vi interessa vi
lascio il link di amazon
sai sono anche a voi perché ho comprato
tutto su amazon è un bel live se volete
vedere altri voi lo shopping cose che ho
comprato bomber like e mettetevi comodi
prende tipo accordo perché ora cambiamo
inquadratura tecnici possono vedere bene
siete pronti bene e allora prima cosa
che vi voglio far vedere ho comprato un
altro di quei kit in cui si sono solo
decorazioni per lo slime che non s'era
questo che in pratica manca uno come
notato perché non ce la faceva da
sfruttare comunque sono tantissimi
glitter però non sono proprio clip per
chi ama varie forme e di queste sono
tipo pallino salire
i brillantini alla scusate se una voce
strana è che ho un mal di gola da un po
di giorni quindi la mia voce un po
stragione live che se lo avevate notato
vediamo quanti hanno notato comunque
sono super carini appunto perché hanno
un sacco di decorazioni particolari però
la boccetta e piccolina quindi non è che
durano tanto però per le challenge sono
ottimi poi abbiamo tutte le finire
cominciamo con le palline gialle c'erano
queste gialle le maglie rosse rosse
demolite rosa per fallire blu blu e
grigie sul collo davis tre parate quindi
c'era questi aspetti di palline questo è
già cioè un pochino più grande comunque
se ne sono già un po di più e colori
ok l'unico buco i colori come ti piace
di più quelle melo è ammessa in ronta
pure musicolor bruno l'avevo mai vista
non avevamo mai avuto né da me non piace
non mi piace
i glitter qua tra l'altro per litro in
pratica nota larghi litter sono vedete
sono dei glitter però più grandi primo
dei coriandoli si luminosi infatti fanno
un bellissimo effetto questi soprattutto
nello slang trasparente delle scaglie lo
scaglione glitter cagli di glitter sera
merda bird e poi questo blu bellissimo
pronta anno e basta mi sembrano non
abbiamo altro così questi quattro erano
quindi questi erano lo stesso nel kit
politichese di più tra questi non è
sempre vero e proprio il tuo colore
preferito
a me piace questo giallo perché un po
dorato a voi quale piace di più ma
sembra torna scaduto al 30 poi del kit
cermis ball
queste sono rosse oggi però quelle rosa
loro viola come viola
fate detto milioni
l'amica rosa poi queste multicolor e
c'erano questi strumenti che più che
altro questi sono per per la plastilina
mi pongo è si è più che lo slime io
usavo da piccola dei coltelli per
decorare dico per gli utenti alle sempre
dorata l'ultima cosa che c'erano il kit
che una delle ragioni per cui lo prepara
la violenza inferiore queste sono delle
decorazioni e frascati aspettate ora le
apre me le faccio vedere decorazione da
slide unicorni se troppo bello chiediamo
ragioni nuovo vi sorgeranno avviso gela
ricordi rena brillanti nautiche belle ci
sono di tanti colori robot che peccato
la figlia che bella una specie l'altro
pezzo di troppo ma dotato di sirena e
poi guardate questi ricordi che carini
ma qui sono glitterate un gelato è un
unicorno che esce da un polo di trovato
poi mangiare la testa direttore marino
quindi tutte queste decorazioni carini
per lo slavo ora questo periodo che
questo c'è volendo si possono anche a
passare alla cover per il telefono o
decorare qualcosa veramente belli
infatti è la ragione principale per cui
ho preso quel sì questo c'è un anche un
pochetto per appenderlo tipo la
collanina hanno svegliati no questa è
uniforme con le ali impegato guardate
che bello sono troppo carini su
decorazioni veramente e queste erano
appunto incluso nel kit e basta vicky
istituzioni enti altro quindi queste
cose che vi abbiamo fatto vedere finora
cosa ne pensate di questo kit e il da
cyber ho preso delle colle glitterato
che forse avete già visto se avete visto
la challenge tre colori di colla
glitterata enel in pratica era un kit da
tre quindi c'erano tre colle ed erano
non mi dicono che berna non mi sembra
che era con queste tre assieme quindi
blu argentato e viola e poi questi tre
che sono più natalizie rosso dorato e
verde allora noi l'abbiamo usata nella
challenge però nei commenti ci avete
scritto che queste cose funzionano anche
da sole quindi si attivano le ha dette
appunto lo stress senza bisogno di
aggiungere la colla quindi fatemi sapere
se volete le proviamo assieme e vediamo
se essere veramente roseline non solo da
queste colle è una figata
quindi la tengono preso queste qua
questo ci sono dei bit
dei pink biz in pratica questi quattro
tasti destro c'è scritto class
wow e sono tagliati posti li tengono
meglio note le caramelle e sono molto
curiosa di provare a metterli uno slam
per il mood live trasparente perché sono
super lucidanti e poi penso che facciano
un bel rumore e permettere quindi fatemi
sapere se volete che trovi anche fosse
poi sempre da tiger preso questo kit per
linee mi piacciono tanto vale che io mi
vergogno poter faccio uno slide una
della tv se non lei quarta la legge sono
capitati capitale e in pratica le ho
prese perché voglio provare lo stesso a
fare uno slam trasparente contante per
linee si sono levate ci sono stati tutti
i colori amici sono tre tonalità di
verde vedi quali ti piace di più tra
questi colori arancione a si ammettesse
molto questo viola tua fucsia e molto
bello questo colore anche questa merda e
qui inserire poi un'altra cosa che ho
preso dalla sanità bellizzi ho detto che
avevo preso tutto da mons maretta con la
bacchetta flyer comunque quello che li
ho presi da hama dove forse ve ne
ricordate perché gli usa
inoltre challenge però le avevo finite
tutte perché le abbiamo usate un sacco
nelle challenge quindi ho deciso di
riprendere perché mi piace un sacco
bari sono le colleghi però dell'aereo in
pratica hanno i glitter dentro ma sono
diverse ad esempio in questa verde
vedete sono di glitter sottili cioè
fallini vedere perché questo impalliditi
invece poi è in questa esatto in questa
rosa ci sono se i pallini che le
paillettes e non vederli lì vi appaia
king's in queste già che ci sono solo le
paillettes vedete quindi sono comunque
un po di pesca tra di loro e sono
bellissime per fare le challenge perché
sono appunto colorati con i che l'inter
questi piace di più tra queste m.na si
no io pensavo che blu quindi regalato
piazzaiolo gibello di tutti io prenderei
solo il viola per mangiare a me piace un
sacco questo celeste perché non so super
chiaro che senza guadagnarci più malata
che stanno ma poi ho preso finalmente il
facebook lei all avvento clay come la
volete chiamare e io l'avevo già provata
una volta però ne vo preso solo una rosa
tempo fa quando feci il butters lime in
miniatura fatemi sapere nei commenti chi
se lo ricorda che mi segue da tempo se
lo ricorderà quando facevo la serie di
salemi miniatura comunque ho preso il
giallo
in pratica era un kit con tutti i colori
infatti tra poco vedrete colori che non
mi piace lo però era inclusi nel kit e
direi che sono ottimi per fare delle
silence e c infatti oltre al giallo c'è
fine
ed è per fortuna è un verde chiaro non
scuro così rimane un pò chiaro magari
anche mischiate con altri colori
rimane un po più chiaro sono proprio
curiosa di provarle tutte quel che si
smetta esce un colorante verde di realtà
più scuro diventa sprigionate poi
abbiamo il blu il blu invece un po più
scuro e un blu scuro blu elettrico non è
un celeste molto carico questo colore il
rosso che è un po che avrà in effetti se
vede sull'acqua si vede sotto di un pò
chiaro questo rosso
abbiamo il nero che è un po pericoloso
questo colore perché insomma scurisce
tutto e potrebbe diventare grigio
marrone
poi abbiamo come di bianco che va bene
con tutto insomma perché si può colorare
lo fallimentari di qualsiasi colore e
poi abbiamo perché l'amore è il colore
preferito di vidal e 33 marrone chiaro e
questo penso che sia il colore più
pericoloso di ostico di come fai lo
slime non sapete benissimo come se cosa
può sembrare è solo marrone sia una
consistenza un po strana insomma lo
sapete dagli slam fames sembrate come la
cassetta di aral e ma senza arale quanti
sono
prendo che completeranno un po costosi
questi curiosa tanto che li volevo e
scrivete nei commenti quali snack si
possono realizzare predetto clay oltre
al butters line così magari andiamo a
realizzarlo insieme a me il colore che
piace di più tra questi e il blu mi
piace molto il bluff anche già un
bellissimo invece quale piace di più di
colore tra questi allora guardate che
cosa ho trovato non mi ricordo nemmeno
dove l'ho trovato un supermercato
eravamo non mi ricordo quale comunque
scrivete nei commenti se vi ricordate
della schiuma di peppa pig esiste la
ricorda chi è un fan da tanto tempo si
ricorderà dello schivo di bel po pig in
pratica è fantastica questo schermo
infatti quando l'ho ritrovata ruffilli
smembrata perché non è come la schiuma
da barba né come il sapone schiumoso in
pratica non so come si danno però rimane
nella forma in cui la modelli è aggiunta
allo strike lo rende fighissimo non solo
fra prima lo rende bellissimo internet
tra la truppa carità molle e quindi fa
un sacco di suoni smr dopo scrivete nei
commenti chi se la ricorda vi ricorre si
faceva anche il tap in tutto andare a
tre mr tom bellissimo il trono e figli
viaggio di rowe benissimo di averla
ritrovata lubich ora dove l'ho presa
però anche supermercato se volete
comprarla anche voi appunto no ma le
ricorda comunque la confezione un po
diversa da quella che avevo quindi spero
che l'effetto sia comunque lo stesso ma
comunque andremo a provarla assieme e
vedremo come ultima cosa questo buco di
ricordo è talmente
bava di unicorno e in pratica l'ho visto
appunto girando su amazon mentre
comprava queste cose per l'islam
mi è apparso come suggerito questo è un
nuovo kit della preoccupata che sarebbe
l'azienda che fa la colla io prendo la
colla trasparente della cleopatra che
però non è molto trasparente rimane un
po giallina pro è l'unica che c'è
disponibile quindi è l'unica che puo
dare volesse un profumo di mandorle a
verità le piazze per che profuma e
quindi hanno deciso di fare anche questo
specie di kit per lo slime un buco di
unicorno nella confezione c'è musica
allora e che ovunque allora non ne va
perché perché lì seduto al naso
comunque andiamo ad aprirlo allora
innanzitutto dalla riunione pozzone
dall'apporto sembrava molto più grande e
questo secchiello ma non è molto grande
e vedete tutte la mia mano lo copre però
andiamo ad aprirlo vediamo cosa c'è
dentro un kit vediamo c'è l'asfalto la
fare lo slime i guanti che insomma c'è
bisogno di ma vabbè poi abbiamo
foglietto in cui ci sono le istruzioni
quindi hanno fatto col questo è una
specie di slide b e un kit e c'è anche
quello della mucca buco di mucca brame
merde poi ci sono qua e loro le loro
colori e qua ci sono le istruzioni
insomma già sappiamo come si fanno tra i
prof
vediamo cosa hanno messo per attivarlo
curiosa di vedere allora abbiamo solo
due boccette rimanenti e inviamo la
colla trasparenza e della cleopatra e
sono quanti ml 100 grammi
poi qua c'è scritto magic product quindi
immagino che queste l'attivatore però
anche i glitter in pratica come mestiere
[Applauso]
hanno messo i glitter direttamente nella
attivatore non nella colla perché non
proviamo adesso a farlo magari così per
farmi un terzo
sarà un terzo di prodotto magico resta
che girare per un minuto dopo che ha
girato con un minuto aggiungere un terzo
di prodotto magico
ecco infine aggiungere un terzo del
prodotto magico ma come quindi bisogna
metter mano che si è agitato e mischiato
con le mani proprio nei minuti non messi
riposare per 5 minuti del proto ok
allora proviamo quindi la colla bisogna
metterla su ok
sono proprio curioso di vedere come s è
shamir l'ha fatto apposta per non far
lavori dei bambini e un adulto per un
ricavo una forma di colla filo 4 perché
sembra più trasparente comunque l'eroe
portarla attesi rimane giallo
mi dispiace quando fanno i kit monouso
che le puoi usare solo una volta per
fare solo uno slam
sarebbe meglio se posso essere un kit in
cui puoi fare più slime comunque vediamo
come non mi ricordo quando l'ho pagato
comunque vi lascio il link
di amazon dovevo comprare descrizione
però non era molto economico diciamo
cioè non era tipo 5 euro 68 devo
ricontrollare comunque vediamo se ne
vale la pena allora ho messo tutta la
colla trasparente ora bisogna mettere
internazioni questo liquido ha
contestato a un terzo
allora quanto sarà un terzo ma a loro
così anziché alla lineetta fa pure
comodo perché ancora poco ma va bene ok
sono stati tutte le genti mettere pure
le mie stesse per farlo vedere
iniziamo a fischiarlo sembra che si sia
già solidificando spero che non esca
troppo solido perché a volte nei kit di
circa 10 secondi ma senza solidificato
si mangia bene così allora è quello che
sentiva scusa per un minuto lo devi
girare lo si guarda te ma che strano ma
per sé senza un po strana ma abusi
unicorno bruco google comunque poi cosa
dobbiamo fare assistente dopo viene
girato per un minuto nel raggiungere un
altro terzo di preparazione di preparato
magico di unicorno
ok anche se mi sembra affatto ci aprono
un tetto e devi seguire le istruzioni
vado mai adesso spot non conosco ancora
un po si ama ok ora lo devo girare
nuovamente stranissima questa
consistenza ed equità gara un minuto per
armarle anima ma le braccia di mamma
papà o la dopo aver girato per un minuto
dice di aggiungere l'altro terzo e di
farlo con mano di mischiarlo a mano per
due minuti
allora primo mettiamo l'antica torre
all'interno ma abbiamo messo l'ultimo un
terzo di questo mischiamo si è staccato
tutta facili o che lo mettiamo sul
tavolo ma anche tutto il tavolo magari
stato lo diventavo ricordo non si sta a
casa domani ok perché sto raccogliendo
tutto insomma
matera allora dice di mischiarlo per
altri due minuti con le mani ok che sta
lasciando un sacco di residui e ho paura
che quella attivazione e forse non lo so
forse era troppo forse lì ci mettiamo
ancora l'altra faccia allora però sta
lasciando un sacco di residui ma spetta
perché deve essere fischiato per due
minuti ti dicevo e poi deve essere e
deve poter rimanere a riposare per altri
5 quindi mai lunghissimo questa protesta
di toma nel frattempo avrei già fatto 10
slime parola un po disintegrato però
sfidiamoci all'istruzione di quindi
consigliamo a mischiarla poco
allungabile adesso però almeno non è più
appiccicoso
poi vediamo dobbiamo lasciarlo riposare
un poco ha comunque lasciato diresti ct
sul tavolo purtroppo è dunque ragazzi
allora abbiamo aspettato e sembra che si
sia solidificato bene vediamo un po
sembra ok è leggermente più
ecco si sta un po strappando quindi è
come se l'attivatore fosse troppo però è
estendibile è sicura in pochi è giusto
leggermente più ha schivato del normale
però comunque è uscito è anche molto
carino devo dire mi piace il colore rosa
con i glitter trasparenti in realtà
colore non ce ne sono solo i clic strass
paesi stanno dando flores
quindi non è male allora diciamo che non
c'è bisogno di questo kit per farlo
perché si può fare semplicemente
prendendo la colla trasparente e l'acido
borico o la soluzione per lenti e
bicarbonato come uso io però non è male
dai è uscito comunque dipende da quanto
costava il kit che non mi ricordo se
vuoi controllare comunque uscito è
uscito carino questo tema troppo
attivato e magari mettere meno alti
valore mettendo meno di motore sarebbe
uscito meglio ma comunque
sì mi piace subendo peccato che si
stratta quello lui all in con il colore
al pesante c'è anche di colore verde che
si chiama costo di naso di mucca
interpretato ora comunque non finisce
qua fateci sapere se volete che facciamo
altri video in cui vi facciamo vedere i
nostri acquisti magari non solo noi ma
anche al 300 un bel laiche se volete
vederle altri ora vi lascio qua 4
castellino esquie cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video in un video video
divertenti video shopping
cliccate su quello che preferite